for some much-needed perspective on what
is going on in Washington we're joined
by Gabriel DeBenedetti a national
political reporter at Politico Gabe good
morning morning setting aside the
editorial practices of Time magazine for
the moment let's start with the Michael
Flynn news the White House says they're
not concerned how nervous do you think
they are about the fact that mr. Flynn
may be cooperating with special
prosecutors let's be clear they're
certainly not not concerned they're very
worried about this this is a been a very
real possibility for a long time but the
real worry here is that he could be
cooperating and therefore implicating
someone higher up the food chain there
aren't that many people higher up the
food chain than him
the question is what this is actually
gonna mean but what the White House is
saying is that he's talking to them
about a plea deal and that's been long
expected so it remains to be seen what
this is actually going to mean but the
White House is definitely nervous the
practices of Moeller tell us that he's
likely going for a bigger fish here if
he's looking to strike a deal with Flynn
is that the understanding yeah that's
absolutely what a lot of folks are
expecting right now the question is who
that bigger fish would be there's of
course the president the vice president
Jared Kushner Donald Trump jr. but we
shouldn't speculate too much about this
because we don't yet know what molar is
really asking Flynn and what Flynn is
willing to talk about here because of
course there are a lot of issues on the
table but ever since the mana Ford
indictments of a few weeks ago the White
House has really been on edge and it
remains to be seen what they're going to
be able to do and go ahead Gabe do you
have a sense of the timeline that we are
working on here in terms of this special
investigation well no in the White House
used to say this was all going to be
done by Thanksgiving 2017 which of
course did not that is past that has
passed so this is a real headache for
the White House because they've been
saying this will be over soon they're
wrapping up all indication is that
that's not the case and that we're still
in for a few more months of this
Muller's team is scheduled to interview
hope Hicks White House communications
director that's getting pretty close to
Trump himself what does it tell us about
the progress here yeah absolutely hope
Hicks is one of the president's closest
advisors been with him for an extremely
long time compared to some of these
other folks and what it tells us is that
this is getting pretty close to the top
we don't necessarily know if any of
these people are implicated than
anything bad but the reality is that if
they're talking to someone like hope
Hicks who's been on the campaign trail
who's been
working with the president for years
that means that this goes all the way up
in the meantime the Trump administration
and Republicans in Congress would very
much like to see tax reform pass they
have set a deadline for themselves the
end of this year how likely is it that
they will meet that deadline well I'm
gonna head a little bit because this
year has had more twists and turns than
anything we've ever seen before it's
likely that they're going to try and
pass something what we don't know is
what that's going to look like they're
desperate to get some sort of
legislative achievement on the table
because this has been a full year with
total Republican control and they
haven't really passed any of their big
legislative priorities tax reform is a
really big one the other issue looming
over Washington this week of course is
sexual misconduct sexual harassment
we've got senator Al Franken rep John
Conyers also implicated in accusations
what is this moving us toward they're
gonna be reforms the change in the
culture yeah the real answer is that
there's going to be a reckoning on
Capitol Hill and just about everyone
understands this now the question is
both when and what is it going to look
like they're definitely going to be
reforms in the reporting process on
Capitol Hill we've already seen some
suggestions that that's happening and
there is a lot of chatter about many
more names coming up of people who have
been involved in this kind of behavior
we just don't know what that timeline is
yet reckoning is correct Gabe just
before we go the Trump administration is
engaged in a fight about the Consumer
Financial Protection Bureau we're going
to talk a little bit more about that
later in the hour but tell us about
where the the sort of back-and-forth is
at this point yes so Richard Cordray who
was in vote of the Bureau has just
stepped down there's a lot of
speculation that he's going to go run
for governor in Ohio as a Democrat and
the administration has said that they're
gonna put Mick Mulvaney the budget
director in charge of the bureau but
Cordray says that his deputy should be
in charge of the bureau so there's a
real standoff right now about who is
going to be in charge of the body that
protects consumers and you know this is
a fight where we have no idea where it's
going but it seems like a lawsuit is
imminent well and we'll see who sits in
the chair on Monday morning Zach stay
tuned Gabe DeBenedetti
thanks as always